foreign
48 kilometers northwest of saigon
armored personnel carriers of the 25th
infantry division
move across the rice paddies of hound
jaw province
launching operation kahala on april 16th
the armored column is momentarily halted
as the tropic lightning troops encounter
small arms fire
from the unseen enemy ahead they fire
back
at spots from which it seems the enemy
fire is coming
vietcong positions have been abandoned
when the men of the 25th reach them
however each hole and tunnel is shot up
before searching it
the apc's continue moving up threading
their way through a hodgepodge of
thickets
bamboo clumps and weeds finally they
emerge from the underbrush into an open
field here
the troops set up a forward cp and take
stock of captured enemy material
the day's sweep has netted nearly eight
tons of rice
taken from various viet cong storage
facilities hidden in the undergrowth
much of this rice once a gift from the
u.s to the vietnamese poor
wound up in the hands of the enemy
aside from the rice vietnamese communist
uniforms
helmet liners and web belts were taken
tunnels in which the enemy supplies were
hidden were destroyed
the uniforms are burned two viet cong
were killed but the main force escaped
continuing the sweep the following day
the apc's cross
more rice fields it's rough going in
spots
and the apc ambulance gets a shaking up
as it climbs over a steep dike
there is no resistance when the men of
the 25th enter this village
and a house-to-house search begins
tunnels used as shelters are
investigated and found to be empty
residents of the hamlet are questioned
regarding the whereabouts of the viet
cong but say
they know nothing the troops are not
satisfied however
since the vc had retreated in this
direction and the village is
in viet cong territory
the intensive probe of the village goes
on
and it is noted that all of the young
men are missing
only women children and old men
remain and so the search moves to the
outskirts of the village
homemade hand grenades and several
weapons were abandoned by the fleeing
viet cong
with discoveries like this the searchers
redoubled their efforts
this propaganda sign was located in a
bunker hidden in the brush
it depicts viet cong soldiers wiping out
an american armored column
while confused u.s pilots drop bombs on
the american forces
another sign is a vc morale booster
shows men and women of various
professions as equals under the vietcong
flag
one prisoner was taken in the swift
envelopment of the area
the viet cong suspect had not been armed
when he was seized
he is interrogated at length by
interpreters
finally he admits he is a viet cong
messenger from the nearby village
they untie him so he can eat
a dinner of fish and rice pleases the
prisoner
and he tells of a tunnel in back of his
house where five
armed viet cong are hiding
the tunnel is a long winding affair and
it yields nothing
it is decided to blow it with a grenade
the infantrymen keep watch in the area
as the tunnel collapses but
no vietcong appear
the informant will be turned over to
brigade intelligence
on the third day of operation kahala
tropic lightning troops enter another
village
the peanut farmers and their families
seem unconcerned
continuing with their daily chores as
the mechanized units move in
the soldiers dismount and begin
searching the area
while checking through the small
graveyard outside the village
one trooper locates some vietcong
uniforms hidden in the brush
here is evidence that the vietnamese
communists use the village
the entire area will have to be
thoroughly searched
in short order new defense positions are
located
and examined they are unoccupied and
devoid of any supplies
more armored personnel carriers move in
around the village
underground shelters are searched and
incriminating documents are located in
some of the houses
upon completion of the village search
the troops burn down these dwellings
then they move on to the next objective
on the final sweep of the five-day
operation the units moved
toward another village reported to be a
vietcong field headquarters
the apc's opened up a path through the
rough spots
this time the occupants of the village
are taken by surprise
several armed vc are trapped and taken
prisoner
in addition several suspects are also
rounded up and held for interrogation
the enemy captives are tied up and taken
to the apc's for transport to the rear
as operation kahala concludes the 25th
reports 27 bunkers and 40 tunnels
destroyed
54 vietcong were killed friendly
casualties were like
high over bin dwang province these
helicopters are on route from benoit to
the tainine area
about 88 kilometers northwest of saigon
vietnamese troops are commencing
operation green eagle
as the assault aircraft approached the
landing zone in the early morning
hours of april 5th a cloud of tear gas
and white phosphorus released by the
choppers
creates a barrier protecting the landing
zone
while the first wave of huey's moves
into landing position
gunships lay down suppressing fire
despite these tactics
enemy ground fire is quite heavy and
several of the assaulting helicopters
are hit
the landing zone is a massive activity
as the american aircraft touched down
momentarily
and the vietnamese troops come swarming
out
incoming fire speeds the men on
before taking off again one helicopter
crew hastily checks for damage resulting
from enemy ground fire
back at the benoit complex the ship is
completely checked and serviced
preparatory to its return to action the
aviation mechanics here provide all
classes of maintenance
even helicopters which have crashed are
brought here for repair or
salvage keeping the fighting choppers in
operation is a full-time job
out on the flight line the choppers
return from the first
phase of their support mission in
operation green eagle
after refueling and rearming they will
commence phase two
picking up the vietnamese troops
mortar aerial delivery a new field
expedient method for hitting the enemy
with mortar bursts
has been devised by the 173rd airborne
at benoit on 5 april a uh-1d helicopter
is being loaded with 81 millimeter motor
shells
dropped from the air mortar shells
strike vietcong locations that are
difficult
or impractical for ground motor crews
on 14 april general harold k johnson
begins a far east tour in korea
general dwight e beach 8th army
commander joins him for a meeting with
korean president chung hee park
in the presidential residence in seoul
the following day
the generals also visit defense minister
sungyeon kim
later general johnson addresses
personnel of first corps
commanded by lieutenant general andrew j
boyle
at camp casey headquarters 7th infantry
division
he confers with brigadier general robert
b smith
assistant division commander of the
seventh the purpose of general johnson's
tour is to observe present capabilities
of the army in the field
at headquarters of the republic of
korea's 26th division
general johnson meets with its commander
and with the commander of the six
rock corps major general he duck kim
they watch a karate demonstration given
by men of the rock
division a karate fighter concentrates
his body into the moment of impact
it takes years of training to develop
this skill
karate experts are among the world's
fiercest fighters
this oriental technique of self-defense
dates back to the days of genghis khan
on the following day saturday 16 april
general johnson talks to the men of the
second infantry division
major general john h childs commanding
the party later returns to seoul where
general johnson talks to members of kmag
headed by major general james h skelton
at eight army support command
headquarters commanded by brigadier
general h
g davison an award is presented to a
member of the 55th aviation company
from a hilltop nearby general johnson
looks over busan harbor
back in august 1950 as a battalion
commander in the first cavalry division
he had fought in defense of the busan
perimeter
toward the end of the day general and
mrs johnson make their farewells at
kimpo
air base the next stop is okinawa
that night they arrive at kadena air
force base
and are greeted by brigadier general
james s billups
the next day general and mrs johnson
attend sunday services
the general pauses in his brief okinawa
for an awards and decoration ceremony
he then inspects a large warehouse
complex
before departing for vietnam for a visit
of several days
visiting the kushi area with major
general jonathan o
seaman second field force commander he
is briefed by major general fred c
wyant 25th division commander general
johnson
talks with the men of the tropic
lightning division and spends much of
his
time in the field with the troops
he discusses operation helping hand 25th
division units are distributing goods
donated by residents of hawaii
he is briefed at a forward tactical
operations center
on the five-day sweep operation kahala
general johnson tells men of the 25th
about the nation's pride in the army
and the army's pride in the achievements
of soldiers serving in the republic of
vietnam
on 15 april a truck mobility test is
conducted in thailand
this is staff sergeant ray goddard of
the u.s army special photo detachment
pacific
today we are at the bang poo vehicle
testing site approximately 20 miles
south of bangkok
with me today is major roger boris and
captain
nori of the thai army uh major boris
would you please explain to us exactly
what arpa is and
some of its functions arpa stands for
advanced research projects agency
its field unit located in thailand is
one of its many field units throughout
the world
engaged in the process of studying
remote
area conflicts uh sir could you possibly
go into a little detail on what you were
going to be doing here today and testing
these vehicles
one of the problems that we've
encountered in thailand has been the
problem of mobility
in the dry season the standard tire army
three-quarter ton truck
located right here is a pretty good
vehicle but in the wet season
it gets stuck in the jungle trails rice
paddies and soft soil areas
today we will be testing out in the bang
foo soft saw area
to show how the mobility of a standard
truck can be increased by just
equipping it with a different sized tire
rather than going to a completely new
vehicle
this three-quarter ton japanese-made
truck a standard vehicle of the royal
thailand army
bogs down after traversing only 40 feet
of mud on standard tires
a modification of the truck's tire
system is the mounting of
four extra standard nine inch tires
using only 15 pounds of air pressure its
progress is slow
and it nearly stops several times
the same type of vehicle using a twenty
inch wide low pressure terra tire
easily traverses the same tidal flats
which so rapidly immobilize the vehicle
with normal tires
after the mobility tests the terra tire
rut
recorded only four inches the precise
soil resistance is determined
by a penetrometer and the information
carefully recorded
the standard tire made a rut 15 inches
deep
next on a planned course one truck with
terror tires
and one with dual standard tires run
back and forth
over their own tracks testing traffic
ability
the territories experience little
difficulty
but the truck with a double standard
tires stops under the added weight of
the mud
caked on the wheels i think the results
of today's testing
will clearly show the increase in
mobility
in soft saw mobility that can be a pain
with both the dual wheel
and the tear attire the standard tire
could not enter the test course
the dual wheel vehicle was able to make
11 passes before becoming immobilized by
lack of engine power
and the teratar equipped three-quarter
ton in the background
is still moving after 16 passes well
telling major boris in addition to the
tests here
what other tests are planned for these
vehicles well after the traffic ability
tests we'll move up north into the rice
paddy areas test through the rice
paddies
and continue on into the jungle test on
remote jungle trails
and that will finish up our testing on
the tire concepts
at the thailand armed forces preparatory
school in bangkok
tests are given twice a month for thai
officers and enlisted men
to determine their proficiency in
english i am major
edward conway map training officer in
the army advisory group
which is a element of the military
assistance command
thailand this is an english language lab
that we have introduced into thailand
under the auspices of the military
assistance program
to thailand it's only one of several
language labs that we've introduced in
the country
this one is located at the armed forces
academy's preparatory school
at the present time we are going to test
a group of candidates for honest
training specifically we're testing
candidates for the
next courses that will start at the
command and general staff college at
fort leavenworth kansas
in august of 1966
this test given 20 april is supervised
by the army military assistance
program's english language officer
and conducted by the linguistic advisor
for the us army advisory group
12 royal thai officers are tested on
their comprehension of the english
language
each of these specially chosen officers
passing the language qualifying test
will be sent to the command and general
staff college at fort leavenworth kansas
others qualifying at other sessions go
to a variety of us army schools
meanwhile at chenbury thailand on the
same day
guests arrive at a training area 80
kilometers southeast of bangkok
to observe a demonstration the korean
embassy military attache in thailand
colonel in woo lee is greeted
colonel james moore chief army advisory
group jmag
and colonel stanley white chief
operations division jmag
joined colonel lee the royal thai army
18th korean rotation company also known
as little tiger
a name it earned during the korean war
has undergone
extensive training the men will replace
the 17th rotation company
and be attached to the seventh infantry
division as part of the united nations
forces in korea
at the range area the visitors observe
the firing of the us
m14 rifle the officers follow with
interest the performance of the men
who will soon be serving in korea
the group is next escorted to the m60
machine gun range
the thai gunners demonstrate their
proficiency
after the demonstration the thai
officers and men are addressed by
colonel lee
all of the men of the company are
volunteers they will depart thailand for
a year in korea on or about 15 june
in mid april a shipment of typhoid serum
donated by
care arrives at santo domingo airport in
the dominican republic
destined for the national hospital in
san cristobal
the serum is loaded aboard a u.s army
helicopter
the airlift to the 82nd airborne
division camp in san cristobal
40 kilometers away begins the sermon is
urgently needed to fight a typhoid
epidemic
spreading through the san cristobal area
and was requested by the dominican
minister of health
at the army base the new thousand dose
shipment is turned over to dominican
hospital authorities
earlier us army medical service had
contributed
another thousand doses immunization is
required for 20 000
cases and care is shipping additional
serum
just outside of santa domingo meanwhile
a shipment of u.s navy water tanks is
being picked up by army engineers
who will establish pure water points for
the populace of santo domingo
now headed for the army engineers camp
these tanks will soon replace the city's
old water system
which is contaminated and considered to
be the chief cause of typhoid at the
engineer base
the 1200 gallon cube tanks are prepared
for use
a water fill hole is cut in the top and
a drain off pipe attached to the bottom
still more tanks arrive at the depot to
be used in the program to combat the
critical water situation
16 kilometers from downtown santo
domingo
a tank is installed at one of two points
supplying water to the inter-american
peace force
and several civilian hospitals twenty
six thousand gallons of potable water
are consumed daily by the iapf
originally the water is taken from a
river filtered
and stored until needed it is then
transported by
tank truck the storage tanks are
protected by a barbed wire
water is drawn off by hoses connected to
portable pumps
the water is then distributed on a
24-hour basis
providing the citizens of santo domingo
with 200 to 300 000 gallons per day
deliveries to the rebel section of the
city are hazardous
in two cases the water truck and the
cameraman's jeep were stoned by hostile
dominicans
after the water had been delivered
in many localities the tanks of purified
water have been painted with initials of
political parties
and anti-american slogans several times
the words yankee go home have been
painted on the trucks themselves
but the water is welcome
it is april 24 in the dominican republic
one year after the revolt that overthrew
the junta of dr donald reed cabral
here in the international zone and along
the main supply route leading into santo
domingo
everything seems peaceful elsewhere in
town
thousands of dominicans demonstrate with
anti-american slogans
throughout the country preparations are
steadily being made for the june 1st
elections approximately 150 kilometers
west of santo domingo
a radio station to relay the election
returns is being constructed
two helicopters from the 283rd aviation
company
stationed at camp randall ferry building
materials from this road to the top of
the hill
this will be the first election and
first constitutional government to be
installed
since juan bosch was elected in nineteen
sixty two
a completely different type of radio
station provides entertainment and news
for the eight thousand man
inter-american peace force in the
dominican republic
seven enlisted men have operated this
afrts station in santo domingo since
last
august it is the only armed forces
station
broadcasting news and programs in four
languages
english portuguese spanish and guarani
which is a paraguayan indian tongue and
requires a guest announcer
the disc jockeys are as international as
their audience
for news the ticker provides the stories
which are edited in the time
honored radio way
the operation is much like that of a
small commercial radio station
originally on the air 18 hours a day the
station expanded to a 24-hour operation
on one april
a 25 000 album record library has been
built up over the past
nine months
music reminds the lonely soldier of home
me
you